[Music]
how to sound like franz liszt so this
video has a little bit of a backstory
because if you've previously seen this
video that I've done for Wired going
over the 16 levels of piano composition
in it I show a potential version of
happy birthday inspired by Liszt but for
me physicality doesn't equal complexity
and as you can hear I was really
glossing over a lot of details behind
his music and I was relying mostly on
this generic sense of virtuosity to
demonstrate this particular point I was
trying to make in the video in the
recent months though I've been learning
a lot more about lists as a composer and
historical figure largely in thanks to
this special research trip to by Marr
that I was generously invited to be a
part of which I'll cover more in depth
in future videos to come but my
viewpoint of lists has really been
changing and shifting I've always put
him into a category of he's this
virtuosa composer that is better off
played by talented twelve-year-old
prodigies but this has been changing and
hopefully I can share some of the things
that I've picked up on in this video and
later of course an updated version of
happy birthday in the style of Franz
Liszt here's a c-sharp minor chord in
its simplest form this would turn it
into something like this
[Music]
here's a cadence going between tonic and
dominant often lists will insert many
diminished chords in between now of
course let's spread these out into very
wide chords there are many ways to break
up a chord here's one of them
often times lists will do this in the
form of Tremeloes
you also find a lot of dotted rhythms
[Music]
and many jumps and better yet here's a
regular arpeggio often times you'll hear
arpeggios done in a fast and dramatic
way you'll hear an abundance of
arpeggios in general
[Music]
and even better yet add in a middle line
say that you're going from one note to a
note higher this will often fill that
gap with a chromatic scale even better
double it up with a parallel interval
like thirds or sixths there are a lot of
filigree runs again here are some
chromatic notes and add in broken chords
to each one of them when you have an
upwards motion like this a lot of times
it'll be done in double octaves say for
example you're on a chord D flat major
to move to another major chord a third
away for example D flat major to B flat
major
traditionally involves a couple of steps
this often uses these chords side by
side and this is called a chromatic
median relationship
[Music]
say that you have a bouncy idea this
would add a little more Sparkle and in
the lower register often times your hue
these very dark dry and spooky type
material in contrast he has many lyrical
and romantic type gestures as well
you
here's a regular group of ascending
courts have them staggered and again
once more here's a chromatic scale
stagger them by alternating between
broken octaves staggering chords and
intervals in general is very common for
example these chords can be staggered in
this fashion notice that in this
particular case there's an overlap
between thumbs a lot of colorful runs
are created by weaving together two
different types of chord sounds here's
one combining major and diminished and
it would turn into something like this
[Music]
later on his music began to lose much of
this type of virtuosity have more
dissonance and less tonality as you can
hear in this excerpt from Raj green but
for this videos arrangement I do want to
include a lot of these points previously
mentioned because list really helped
progress piano writing forward with
these elements and now after literally
dozens of takes here is happy birthday
in the style of Franz Liszt
[Music]
you
[Music]
like I mentioned previously there will
be more videos about list coming pretty
soon so make sure you look out for those
and thank you so much for watching I'll
see you in the next one bye
you